هل اقنعك السبب في تعليق تمويل الاونروا
لمجرد ان افرادا او عددا من الموظفين
اتهموا
بالتعامل مع
حماس لا انا لم اقتنع ابدا بهذه الاسباب
واعتقد ان توقي الاعلان عن المعلومات من
قبل السلطات الاسرائيليه اولا وبعد ذلك من
قبل الولايات المتحده والحكومات الغربيه
فيه الكثير مما يدعو الى القلق لان هذه
الممارسات بدات من فتره طويله والانروا
لديها قائمه بالموظفين في الضفه الغربيه
وفي قطاع غزه والسلطات الاسرائيليه تطلع
على اسماء الموظفين بشكل دوري وكان
باستطاعه السلطات الاسرائيليه ان تعبر عن
قلقها ازاء موظف من هنا وموظف من هناك
ولكنها لم تقم بذلك بالنسبه الى السؤال
الذي يجب ان يطرح على الجهات المانحه
لماذا اختاروا ان يطلقوا هذه المعلومات
الان ويعرضوا عمل الانر للخطر برايك انت
لماذا
اعتقد ان الاسباب في غايه الوضوح وانا
متاكد من ان المشاهدين الكرام قد لاحظوا
ان اسرائيل تعمل منذ سنوات طويله حتى قبل
وصول هذه الحكومه الحاليه من اجل التخلص
من وكاله الانر وهم يواجهون صعوبات للقيام
بذلك غير انهم انتهزو فرصه من خلال هذه
المزاعم التي يجب طبعا ان يحقق بها ولكن
يستخدمون هذه اللحظه لفرض الضغوط القسوى
على الاونر ورئيس مجلس الوزراء نتنياهو
بنفسه قال ان الونر ليس لديها مستقبل في
قطاع غزه بعد انتهاء الحرب ولكن معظم
الناس يعرفون ان وكاله الاونر هي جهه لا
يمكن التخلي عنها لا يمكن ان تستبدل وهي
تحظى بثقه الجماعه المحليه ا مشكله
نتنياهو مع الاونور لماذا لا
يريدها
الحجه الاسرائيليه هي ان الانر تستخدم من
اجل اجراء او الابقاء على مساله اللاجئين
الفلسطينيه مساله مفتوحه هذا غير صحيح ان
الانر تتعامل مع اللاجئين الفلسطينيين
بنفس الطريقه التي تتعامل معها الوكالات
الامميه الاخرى غير صحيح ان الان تميز
التعامل مع اللاجئين الفلسطينيين ان
الفلسطينيين باستطاعتهم ان يحافظوا على
حاله اللاجئين او صفه اللاجئين حتى انتهاء
هذه الحاله بالنسبه الى افغانستان واللجوء
الى باكستان او ايضا في ايران وضع
اللاجئين القانوني هو نفسه نتحدث عن مساله
سياسيه اساسيه هي محاوله لانهاء مساله
اللاجئين ال فلسطينين من قبل الاسرائيليين
كجزء من الصراع الاسرائيلي الفلسطيني الان
تعليق التمويل كيف يمكن ان يكون اثره على
مليوني فلسطيني في قطاع
غزه اعتقد ان المشاهدين الكرام يجب ان
يعرفوا ان ليس فقط السكان في قطاع غزه سوف
يتاثرون بل ال ثير يتوسع الى ما بعد قطاع
غزه ان التمويل لا يتوقف عند حدود عمل
الانرو في قطاع غزه ولو انه العمل الاهم
الان غير ان ذلك سوف يؤثر على كل اللاجئين
الفلسطينيين في الضفه الغربيه في الاردن
في سوريا وفي لبنان هناك اكثر من 6 ملايين
لاجئ فلسطيني مسجلون مع الانر يعتمدون على
الاونر لتلقي الطعام والتعليم والخدمات
الصحيه والماوى الى اخره وبالتالي نتحدث
عن مساله اكبر من حدود قطاع غزه حتى قبل
بدايه هذه الحرب كانت الانرو تواجه مشاكل
ماليه خطره وهذا يؤثر على عملياتها وكانت
سوف تتاثر عملياتها لو لم تحصل على
التمويل حصلت على تمويل في حالات الطوارئ
في قطاع غزه ولكن تعليق التمويل ووفقا
لاداره الاان قد يعني ان الوكاله لن يكون
باستطاعتها ان تدفع رواتب اكثر من 13 الف
موظف في المنطقه بعد شهر شباط فبراير انلي
المسؤول السابق في وكاله الاونر وحدثنا من
ساو باولو شكرا لك